[Musique]
y'a juste un moment il faut dire ma
réforme elle consiste en cela de façon
simple comment peut-on parler de façon
aussi compliqué aux français moi je veux
bien qu'on discute de quelque chose dont
on discute de quoi la position du
premier ministre celle du président de
la république de celle de jean paul
delevoye de celle de tel ou tel ministre
qui prend la parole sur ce sujet d'abord
l'échec de la méthode emmanuel macron on
mesure l écart abyssal qui lie à entre
la promesse initiale de son élection de
réconcilier tous les français et le
caractère anxiogène de l'ensemble de ses
prises de position il réussi le défi de
mettre tout le monde dans la rue alors
même qu'il n'y a pas de réforme précise
et un problème avec la méthode emmanuel
macron et son gouvernement que marine le
pen ramener l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 60 ans pas dire qu'
aujourd'hui qui dans le monde est ce
qu'il ya un état qui nous explique que
vraiment l'âge de la retraite de 62 gens
comme ils en france il faut le ramener à
60 ans tout ça n'a aucun sens ne tient
pas la route et plus personne ne sait
exactement où le bal mans par dell à
quelques considérations très général
veut aller et donc ça incontestablement
ça engendre du stress de l'anxiété et ça
fait peser une menace dont tout un
chacun se dit elle pèse sur mon propre
régime de retraite puis nous sommes
attachés à sanctuariser les droits
familiaux et conjugaux
ça veut dire que nous sommes attachés un
système par répartition un système
mutualiste donc contre un système
individualiste par point ça fait deux
ans qu'on a de la concertation deux ans
qu'on n'a pas de texte deux ans concret
de l'anxiété et deux ans qu'on n'a pas
réformé ce pays nous nous avons porté
des vraies réformes de retraites ce soit
en 93 en 2003 en 2000 en 2010 qui ont
été structurantes prendre en otage les
les
les usagers du train du métro et
beaucoup de monde est quelque chose
d'insupportable
je demande simplement qu'il y ait un
service minimum garanti dans les
transports publics
voilà les transports publics aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de france à des
millions de françaises et de français
qui sont dépendants des transports
publics pour pouvoir aller venir pour
pouvoir aller au travail et il se
retrouve prise en otage
[Musique]